as i mentioned already natural selection
is my sub stack which is at
naturalselections.subsite.com
i haven't had nearly as much this week
as last week but this week i did post
some of the remarkable portraits uh that
a canadian photographer by the name of
dana ponte boy he and i have been in a
lot of conversation i'm not actually
sure i'm pronouncing his name correctly
i hope i am dan um
i posted some of the remarkable
portraits that he took
on the second saturday of the trekkers
convoy of the truckers for freedom
protests in um
in ottawa which i've now begun to hear
people calling an um an occupation in a
in a good way like this is you know this
we're here we are here and we're going
to stay here until the mandates go away
and that's and that is part of what
we'll be coming back to after we do our
ads and such here well i feel like
occupation actually
is a little bit like i think the term
woke
right some of us were not sure what to
call the woke revolution back when
people typically called it uh social
justice warriors
right because social justice warriors is
pejorative and if you want to just
simply say this thing fails on its
merits i don't need to you know i don't
need to label it badly in order to
reveal how broken it is the point is
woke is a term that's actually viewed
positively inside the movement and those
of us on the outside can use that term
and say look this is nonsense it's not
what woke used to mean and i think
occupation you know i've seen a lot of
battling around it doesn't strike me as
negative because of course you know uh i
will speak for myself i was part of the
occupy movement which became an
absurdity but it started out as a
legitimate complaint about the tarp
program and the financial collapse of
2008 and what it revealed about
corruption and the point was occupation
was a method when we didn't have a
method to get the attention of the
government and say actually this is
unacceptable you can't do this to us
right too big to fail is an excuse to
bail out people who caused this and it's
falling on our backs occupation was the
method and
i must say i am um
excited to see that occupation
has been
um
upgraded
by
clearly
clearly working-class people
um who have a legitimate
gripe with the federal government which
has obviously captured the imagination
of many many millions of people not just
in canada but across the globe
[Music]